I mean and today we're going to talk
with you about bringing your kubernetes
to the cloud with anthos but before we
go into that we'd like to introduce
ourselves
I mean chakras and I'm one of the
engineering leads working on anthos and
GK and my team is focused on making it
possible to manage and monitor all your
kubernetes infrastructure whether it's
in the cloud or on Prem I've been
working with kubernetes for several
years now and I've lived through a few
of these different tech transitions for
example from bare metal to containers as
well as from monoliths to micro services
and the thing that brings excitement to
me is actually the velocity that you can
achieve from these modern technologies
and by allowing you to focus on your
business okay I'm Matt DeLeo I'm one of
the product managers working on anthos
and gke I've been on the team for the
past three years initially focusing on
some of our more infrastructure pieces
of kubernetes but now I'm focused on
making it easier to manage workloads and
kressler clusters running anywhere
sure thank you so here's our agenda for
the next thirty minutes we're gonna
start out by exploring the problem space
a little bit more and the challenge in
the challenges you're facing next we're
going to look into how anthos is
uniquely positioned to help you address
these challenges and then finally we're
going to have a deep dive on one of the
solutions we're providing an Anthes for
observability and management so let's
get started I wanted to spend a few
minutes really looking at the challenges
kind of recapping a little bit of what
Aparna said about the challenges that
you're facing and how containers
kubernetes and ultimately anthos can
help you address these challenges
so as apana mentioned a few moments ago
so companies are leaning more and more
on your IT organization to deliver
solutions that help them adapt quickly
to changes in market in the market
consumer demand and also to create
competitive advantage in addition and
we'll explore this later you're being
asked to run these solutions in
multitudes of environments both in cloud
and on-premises all while maintaining
your initial focus which is reducing
risk and cost this is a tough challenge
but it's not impossible containerization
can help your developers and operators
be more productive and kubernetes
coupled with anthos can help you run
efficiently wherever you need to be
running so as you probably know
containers are necessary building block
that's why we're all here in San Diego
this week for sure but they have really
important to make your teams more agile
in a nutshell containers are easier to
manage than traditional solutions be it
bare metal VM based for example when you
need to make a change to a production
application there's no need to patch a
binary on a VM or the machine just toss
out the old container and place it with
a new one when operating containers
there's less infrastructure to manage
patch and otherwise maintain another
major benefit is that containers give
you reproducible and consistent
artifacts throughout your dev test
and production deployment stages this
makes it easy for easier and faster to
develop and debug your workloads then
that result is that developers and
operators can focus more on the
development instead of managing and
patching infrastructure but then you may
be thinking to yourself containers by
themselves are not enough you need
tooling to manage and run these
container based applications kubernetes
is that tooling now one of the key
features of kubernetes is that it
provides an abstraction from the
underlying infrastructure this is
particularly useful given the challenges
and goals we've discussed till now up
till now with kubernetes your developers
and service operators can learn a common
set of tooling api's etc and apply them
anywhere kubernetes runs so now that we
know that containers and kubernetes help
us run workloads anywhere why would we
need to here's some of the top hybrid
and multi cloud use cases you've told us
about the first one on the top left here
is invoking legacy dependencies while
you can move certain workloads to cloud
there will always be some on-premises
services either have not or cannot be
moved to cloud in the middle and the top
is service availability we hear all the
time that in order to achieve your
particular latency and availability
requirements you need to deploy your
application across multiple regions and
serve traffic to them another one we
hear a lot especially in the multi cloud
context is developer choice it's
important to give your team's access to
the preferred managed services which
will reduce their friction and help them
move a lot more quickly and that brings
us to data locality and regulation on
the bottom bottom left their regular
tournament requirements often come up
where you're required to keep your data
and compute in specific regions
throughout the world this can be on
premises it could be in multiple clouds
it could be anywhere another one that's
kind of emerging at the bottom of the
last two are sort of emerging but local
execution comes up a lot where is
providing mission-critical applications
to local often on-premises environments
the examples we have here warehouses
branches even factories and you want to
do this in a way that allows you to
build manage and maintain these
applications using modern tool and
tooling driven from cloud and finally in
the bottom right we've got edge
computing it's very similar to local
execution but it's more constrained
you've got more remote connectivity
problems and you've got non-traditional
computer environments so we saw how
adopting containers and kubernetes help
improve velocity increased portability
we saw many reasons why you would want
to run workloads anywhere but now how do
you do this efficiently and effectively
across all of these different
environments and that's why we built
anthos it's a software stack that uses
kubernetes as its foundation and
provides through additional layers which
Amuro will show us in a minute
consistency security and management
capabilities which in turn accelerates
your developer velocity to tell you more
about anthos and how it doesn't I'll now
turn it over to you guys see me okay
okay okay so we're going to cover a
little bit of an overview upon I cover
some of that so can I walk through some
of these quickly but again the idea is
you look at anthos as the software stack
that enables you to do the operations
the management and of course all your
apps so and this is gonna we're going to
talk about in this talk a little bit
focus on the infrastructure and also the
manage operation so upon a cover this we
are talking about how anthis is a
software based act with an open software
and abstracting the infrastructure way
but when you look at anthos deployment
option I think that's kind of where we
really differentiate it is we've looked
at all of where our a lot of our
customers are and the reality is you
customers are running things everywhere
from Google cloud platforms from vSphere
from some of the other cloud providers
bare metal or even you have some of you
have your own kind of kubernetes cluster
and this was taken in conservation as we
were building anthos and how it can fit
and actually help you run across all of
these environments so kind of coming to
you as a customer where you are instead
of trying
bring you and force you to a specific
place where you want to run so when I
look at the components of anthos and how
it fits this is how it is how I like to
mentally think about it this is the
first box on the bottom you have anthros
my gray and you can bring new
applications to anthos kind of have some
kind of a green field but also as upon
dimensions there was a lot of existing
applications that you have to
accommodate to you would love to migrate
you have to use some of those
capabilities so migrate which we went to
GA I think this week or last week helps
you a lot with that
the next part okay I have my app on
alright somewhere where there are on it
and this is where we give you some
office okay this is where we try to give
you some options again between Jiki on
the cloud between Antho Jiki deployed on
bare metal and between anther Jiki
deployed on some of the other cloud
providers so the next part is okay I got
all of these clusters I want to manage
them together what do I do and this is
where having connect who's going to talk
about the Indian is going to talk about
more in detail comes in I say okay how
can I have this visibility and
centralized visibility across all of
these clusters and manage my
applications so okay I got my clusters
of running I got my applications of
running I can see them all what do I do
next okay you might want to make sure
that all of these clusters are
configured correctly and the same to the
same standards you have an enterprise
and this is when anther config
management comes in making sure that all
your clusters are consistent making sure
that all the configuration are
consistent across nine o'clock provider
so you got your clusters up and running
you've got your applications up running
everything is okay okay now I got want
to get this second level of visibility
into how my applications are wrong I
want to get this deep type into kind of
my SLO my performance and this is where
anther service which comes in
so anther service mission adds this
additional layer of visibility at this
additional layer of control on the
infrastructure layer by using ISTE you
to give you that there's almost like
x-ray like visibility across all of your
apps to see exactly where it's the
latency which apps are talking to each
other which ones are affecting the
performance of your application which is
specifically critical as you move to
micro services okay so you got your
service man
now what they do okay let's get more
application and this is where
capabilities such as cloud ron GCP
marketplace comes in and more and more
applications going to be running from
google and some some other partners to
help you run all of these applications
so as you look at this this actually
helps you this helps you look at your
application infrastructure where you are
in their journey and get with you and
introduce their existing component
whatever components you need to manage
where you are in your journey so
focusing a little bit about energy k so
G key is kind of the foundation of a lot
of this G key of course is you Anthony
he is our kubernetes distribution at
Braun's the first iteration of that as
upon I mentioned five years ago came in
and live on GCP and it's why one of the
most widely kind of regarded one of the
respected kind of communities bathroom
but the idea is you don't have to think
about a lot of these technologies this
is like production great applications
you get access to other services you can
easily start easy upgrade all of these
things that shouldn't take you a lot of
time because you want to make sure that
you are focusing on your business and
focus on your application but then this
comes in kind of Jiki anthro cheeky on
pram which is you got a turnkey
production grade conformal kubernetes
you got running that the best practices
you got access to continue services or
DCP again easy upgrade path a lot of the
capabilities that you want to get from
the cloud a lot of customers came to us
and say hey I would love to have this
running on my infrastructure I have this
existing s ap applications I have this
existing other applications that it
cannot move and I need this keep all of
these capabilities and all the
experience that I'm used to on the cloud
so this is where anthis yukio and Prem
kind of comes in so yeah so the next
part of that isn't going to talk about
I'm gonna hand it over to
to talk about that layer of
observability and the layer of
management across and having this
visibility across so uh matt has given a
bit of an overview for why customers are
coming to anthos and what you can get
from anthos and then Omer did a bit of a
deep dive into several of the components
and I'm gonna really dive deeper into
the technology and the multi cluster
observability and management features so
I'm gonna start by talking about
connecting your clusters to Google with
their single pane of glass and I'll then
give some demos so just to start with
some of the terminology here you've got
kubernetes clusters they can be on GCP
they can be on cram they can be on other
clouds and the first step is to register
those clusters with Google's control
plane and the GK hub those clusters get
connected to GCP by installing a
connecting agent and then you can login
and interact and view the workloads in
those clusters so we have an amazing new
eye for gke and we've extended that to
kubernetes clusters anywhere with this
single plane of glass you you can
interact with all your GK clusters as
well as GK on Prem clusters which are
actually connected when they are created
via this single pane of glass you can
monitor and manage your workloads no
matter where they are you can dig into
the cluster resources and actually see
what the version of the cluster is how
many nodes are in that clusters what the
CPU and memory are you can actually view
and inspect all the different workloads
that are running in there and whether
they are help healthy or whether they
might have a problem
the gke UI also provides additional
context and surfaces relevant
information for example if there is an
error if there is a problem it'll raise
those
alerts or warnings and make them really
easy and actionable and if you have
sufficient permissions you can also
manipulate resources directly from the
UI for example scaling up and deployment
or changing the version of an
application so the cloud console really
provides a consistent UI for your
operators and your developers across
clouds and across clusters now I'm going
to talk about how you connect your
clusters to Google to connect your
clusters you run a agent that runs in
your cluster and connects to Google
looking at the diagram here in the
bottom right hand side this is your
infrastructure and this is your
kubernetes clusters and on the top
this is GCP and Google Cloud and so you
can see we've got a few different keys
and locks here these relate to different
security operations that are happening
and when I first talked about installing
the agent so you see there's a lock and
a key with the JCP cloud logo actually
you installed that agent and you use GCP
service account for the authentication
and authorization and a encrypted
connection gets form to Google from that
agent connecting your cluster to Google
if for any reason the agent gets
disconnected you will periodically
attempt to reconnect when you visit the
cloud console after you've connected a
cluster is it in the upper left-hand
corner there you can see there's a
little key and the kubernetes icon this
is actually you logging in as you and in
the bottom left is the API server with
the lock and this is where role based
access controls that are sent by you and
your administrators come into play so
actually depending on what your
privileges are when you log in you can
do different things from the cloud
console and administrators can
essentially scope permissions to least
privilege to ensure that you can only do
the things that you need to be able to
do in that cluster now that I've told
you about how to securely log into your
clusters and interact with them we're
gonna go ahead and move
to the demos so in the first demo I'm
going to talk about deploying the
connect agent and registering your
cluster then logging in and showed you a
little bit about the cloud console so I
have a kubernetes cluster here it's just
a single node kind cluster which is
kubernetes and docker and it's 115 you
can see I have the custard there it has
a few the small number of pods running
and a few deployments now if we go to
the cloud console here you can see we
have a number of different kubernetes
clusters already in this project we've
got GK clusters as well as clusters from
other clouds and we are going to
register this cluster and then log in
and interact with it so we're hitting
the register button I'm just gonna call
it my cluster and we are here in San
Diego and it's a kubernetes and docker
cluster and I'm gonna go ahead and
generate the registration command so
what you can see in the bottom there is
actually certain things are waiting to
happen and there's a particular command
here that takes information about the
cluster so that it can deploy the agent
for example the cluster config in the
cube config path as look as well as a
local key file that local key file is
the JCP service account that I talked
about for connecting the agent back to
cloud so you can see here I have the GCP
service account right here I'm just
going to go ahead I already have a
command here with all that information
so what this command is going to do is
actually install the agent and form the
connection back to Google and what we
should see is after a few moments the
related agent will get deployed in the
cluster and we'll see updates here in
the background let's see so now let's
deployed the agent now let's hope the we
see the two green dots so now what this
means is now the cluster has registered
and gotten connected to Google now you
can set some more labels but I'm just
gonna go ahead and skip adding more
labels to it and now what you can see is
that in addition to the other clusters
that I had I now have my cluster now as
I mentioned once you've registered your
cluster you actually have to log in and
you have to log in with your credentials
so for this demo I've actually set up a
kubernetes service account granting me
cluster admin just so I can do all the
different types of operations that I
walk within this cluster so I'm gonna
paste the key to go ahead and log in and
now you can see I've got the green dot
I've got my clusters and now I also have
it's showing me the cluster size they
CPU in the memory and we could actually
dive in deeper and see what's going on
in that cluster you can see things like
the master version as well as the CPU
and memory and you can see the nodes as
well so there's only one node in this as
we showed here so we can see that node
and we can see the different pods as
well that are running so let's go ahead
now we've connected this cluster I
mentioned that we had given permission
to actually deploy workloads into this
cluster so let's go ahead we're gonna
deploy an application really quickly so
I'm just gonna use a hello world
container here
and I'm gonna put it in I'm gonna call
it hello world and actually I'm gonna
deploy it into that cluster that I just
created so now what this is doing is
actually it's going through the
connection and actually deploying this
particular application so what we should
see is it'll declare the intent on the
API server and then the API server is
gonna reconcile that intent by creating
the deployment and spinning up all the
pods so you can see there it's now
created the hello world deployment and
we can see that everything is green and
actually we'll just hop over here into
the cluster and look at the deployments
as well so there we are
there's the hello world deployment 3 and
3 so in this demo I showed you how to
deploy the connect agent and get your
cluster connected to the cloud how to
login and then how to interact with that
cluster via the UI now I'm gonna move on
to the second part of the demo so I'm
going to talk about monitoring debugging
and performing some updates and so this
is gonna show you how the cloud console
really surfaces information helps you
dump debug and troubleshoot how with the
appropriate permissions you can actually
make changes and resolve them as well as
some of the other common operations that
you encounter so we're gonna start here
we'll start on the workloads page and
what you can see is you can see there's
a problem here and actually let's just
filter it down
and so you can see there's a problem
with this one deployment here it says
does not meet minimum availability so
let's go ahead and dive into that
particular deployment now right off the
bat you can see that it's surfacing the
errors to me it's saying there's a image
pull back off error and I can actually
click on that and see specifically
what's going on and as you can see here
if it's kind of small it looks like
somebody made a typo and so we actually
this particular image isn't available
and so you can also see that we want to
have one of this particular one of these
pods running but it's not successful so
let's go ahead we see that there's a
typo so we'll go in here and edit and
we're just gonna fix that particular
error now we're gonna save the changes
and what this is gonna do is change the
image that is related to this particular
deployment and you can see that it
starts taking action immediately so now
we've resolved this particular issue the
typo the image was pulled successfully
the deployment is green and the related
pods are also available so this
fantastic we had a problem it surfaced
to us in the UI immediately and we were
able to resolve it quickly now we know
that later today there's gonna be a lot
of traffic load for this particular
application so let's go through a few of
the common scenarios there the first
thing we'd like to do is we only have
one replicas which doesn't really give
us much redundancy or much scale so the
first thing let's do is let's go ahead
and scale this application up so we're
just gonna give it
let's give it five replicas now what's
gonna happen when I click this button is
actually it's gonna say instead of just
one pod for this deployment I want five
pods for this deployment and then it's
gonna spin up all those pods now will
likely catch it here when it's starting
up so you can see we wanted five and it
started creating the other ones
let's hit refresh all right so now we've
got five replicas running of hello world
and we can see that all the pods
associated with this are running now
this is great via the UI a few clicks we
just scaled up our application but you
know how it is like as soon as you think
you're all set
there's a problem or there's some new
feature you want to roll out so what
we're going to do next is we're actually
going to roll out an update to this
particular deployment so I'm just gonna
leave three seconds in between who has
the different pods spin up and we're
gonna move it from 102 2.0 and so what
should happen here is at no time should
we have less than five pods running and
actually what it's going to do is it's
going to roll the update so it'll spin
up a 2-0 pod and shut down a 100 pod and
then spin up another two dido and shut
down a 1.0 so that we always have at
least five replicas running at any one
point of time so we're rolling out the
updates and you see that actually we had
those five running and we start getting
some more running because the we're kind
of seeing this rolling state as some
spin up and some shutdown from the old
version 1.02 the new version so you can
see we actually we've now got the
deployment is gone but some of the pods
are still running that's gonna take
another few more seconds before the old
pods get shut down some of them are
starting to shut down there
all right so now we've done the update
this particular deployment has five of
the new pods running and we've scale
we've updated the application so that's
the the second demo and now we're gonna
switch back to the slides
King switches back to the slides please
thank you
all right so Matt talked a bit about the
velocity as well as where people have
their infrastructure need to be running
and then armored dug into anthos and
really an overview of many of the
different components and then I went
through and actually showed you a demo
about connecting your clusters to Google
as well as interacting with them so
that's really the end of the talk and we
want to open it up now for questions as
well as invite you to come talk to us
either after this talk as well as at the
reception this evening we do have people
here all week as well at coop con in the
community lounge as well as in the booth
so thank you everyone
you